fact is national border patrol council
president brandon
judd brandon thanks for taking time on
saturday you just heard
rich's report there and in the rgv the
agents tell me
they had about 1640 apps apprehensions
that is in the last 24 hours it's really
getting pretty much at a point they
haven't even seen in their 20-year
career
what what is the solution what do we do
what do you make of what's happening
there on the ground on the border
oh the solution is very simple we've got
to look at
what has worked in the past we also have
to look towards the future i mean
as long as we continue to release people
into the united states
after they violate our laws with no
consequences people are going to
continue to come that's the simple
fact obviously people are coming to this
country because this is the greatest
country in the world
we do have you know we we have the
biggest open arms
we want to accept people into this
country but we want to do it legally not
illegally and that's the problem is is
both the right and the left want to
continue to politicize this
issue but the left wants to excuse
illegal immigration they want to excuse
the cartels abusing these children
taking these children
and sexually abusing them physically
abusing them mentally abusing them
you know they want to excuse this and
and they continue
by policy they continue to perpetuate
this situation and it's it's
gaining cartels ground and it's making
them billions of dollars
every year off of human misery brendan
you mentioned
the release of the migrants and we've
covered that story quite extensively but
you sent me this morning a story
of what's happening in arizona where the
texas
dps department of public safety made a
traffic stop
and released some migrants explain
yeah this is just a good example of how
overwhelmed
the united states border patrol is right
now uh texas dps made a stop there there
were
17 people in a vehicle i mean that's
dangerous right there i mean we just saw
what happened in el centro california
when that vehicle crashed and killed so
many people
but these smugglers they don't care
about people
but when they overwhelm the system then
we don't have the resources to go up and
take these people into custody dps
arizona dps had to release these 17
individuals
we don't know who they are we don't know
what countries they're from we don't
know what their intentions are here in
the united states
and that's extremely scary and when you
couple that with the 61
000 people that were able to evade
apprehension in the month of february
and march
that is a scary situation for this
country brandon we just got about 30
seconds but i do want to ask you vice
president harris has said she will
travel
soon to guatemala and also to mexico
but not to the u.s border what do you
say yeah because if she goes to the u.s
border people are going to expect her to
fix the problem
so she avoids it that is that's
disgusting
because that's putting politics ahead of
what's best for this country
that's what the president the vice
president is supposed to do
brandon judd president of the national
border patrol council thank you
for joining us and weighing in a big
story we will continue to follow it with
you thank you sir